all right superlatives time super bowl
edition
uh chris i'm going to give you the first
crowd since i'm still in the process of
formulating well all right i'm going to
go with just one real we've we've hit a
lot of the game i want to do one big
picture okay
just like what a show is my first
superlative and i mean that from the
whole nfl the whole weekend considering
the circumstances i do want to just give
it love mike i know i texted you on
saturday night i thought the nfl honors
were phenomenal considering the way it
had to be done they're doing it in the
stadium in la everything like that steve
harvey was hilarious the guys who
received the awards the players in the
nfl were all awesome too so that the
pre-game show yesterday you know the
national anthem half-time show all of
that the nfl put on a great show and i
just for the year we had and again to
get all the games in have the super bowl
and the way they dressed it up this
weekend still was really amazing so i do
want to give the cred a lot of credit to
the nfl for that right off the bat
it felt like a perfectly normal super
bowl sunday and you never looked at the
stands and thought where are all the
people now having 30 000 cutouts in the
stands helps create the the atmosphere
where it feels like a normal super bowl
but it did feel like a perfectly normal
super bowl experience which i don't
think we ever would have expected for
this season i'm going to see your what a
show and i'm going to raise it to what a
season
because i never would have
ever expected all of the games to be
played we all went into the season
thinking inevitably there will be games
postponed now there was one game that
was moved from week four to week seven
right other than that there was no
movement there was no cancellation every
game was played and there was no need
for what we also thought was inevitable
chris an extra weekend of games they had
it baked in they could have done a week
18 they could have done a week 19. they
could have slid the super bowl back a
few weeks if they wanted to because the
the typical crush of humanity around the
super bowl wasn't going to be there so
they had flexibility and it's not like
there's a lot of other conventions set
for tampa for the month of february
given the pandemic the fact that they
got everything in on time got the
playoffs in on time with minimal
disruption we had titans ravens browns
three incidents of outbreaks or
something like outbreaks but they
managed to put the fire out they were
flexible with the protocols you know
they understood they're not going to
keep guys from getting it the key is
keeping guys from spreading it they
worked with some inherent flaws in the
process that weren't their fault it's
just the way that the the virus works
the incubation period the testing delays
things that we thought would happen like
almost instantaneous results that didn't
happen and they still found a way to
work through that and and let me just
say one last time to all the people out
there who think that i am upset that
this happened that we in some way were
against the nfl getting the season do
you not understand that our revenue our
income is tied to the ability of the
games to be played
we were trying to sound the alarm
because there were moments where you're
like are they really ready for this do
they really know what they're getting
into are they really prepared for the
challenge this season is going to entail
and they were but they also
had a major
chunk of luck
that that helped keep this thing on
track as well but um i'm very look
yeah yeah we're we're never going to
convince 100 of the people that we
actually want the games to be played but
it's asinine to think that anybody who
makes a living off of this sport didn't
want the sport to be played chris it's
beyond asinine yeah listen i know
hundreds of thousands of people have
died i mean how dare we you know send
some warning shots across the bow just
to go are we sure we're ready can we do
this the right way and we were just
posing questions to make sure things
were done the right way that's all it
came down to because we wanted it to
happen so i'm with you how dare you like
upstage my what a show for what a season
what a jerk you are on monday after the
super bowl all right is that your third
is that your next one is jerry what is
the shirt what is that
we can glue that on there for the rest
of every superlands ever right all right
but i think the next one just to have
fun would be the uh because you know i
like to do my our matey the walk the
plank award or maybe because the
buccaneers front four
made mahomes look like he was on the
plank ready to jump to the sharks but no
really i mean
that that was a phenomenal performance i
don't know any other way to say it the
front four we talked about it for two
weeks you know they were going to be
told you got to dominate you guys got to
win this football game we got to be able
to have seven in coverage and play two
safeties back and do all that uh
shaquille barrett jpb
vida veya and dama consu i mean wow
you know we look at this are you kidding
me is this is this like wiley coyote in
the roadrunner or the damn quarterback
like what the hell which way did he go
i mean holy crap yeah i mean mahomes did
all this running yesterday and you
talked about the next-gen stats nobody
scrambled more than anybody
on a toe he's going to get surgery on in
the next 10 days i mean he was under
duress in a game they needed to protect
them a little bit better than ever
before
they were worse than ever before and
that was of course because of that great
defensive line and great job by jason
like accumulating that talent there for
that football team
you made the comment last hour about the
toes seemed fine in the championship
game you know when you have an injury
like that and we're not doctors but we
have both been injured some more
seriously than others
but
when you when you
have that ligament type injury
all it takes is that one moment where
you push it too hard exactly and it goes
again right and that's what happened
last night with those guys chasing him
without his tackles there with the
bright lights in the big stage of the
super bowl with everything riding on it
he clearly early in the game
put too much pressure on the toe pushed
off of it too hard and and there it went
again messed it up again and he was back
where he started almost against the
browns three weeks earlier yeah but uh
that's what happens when you've got that
that defense that can bring the heat and
it also helps to have both of your
tackles out from the standpoint of
chasing the guy around i'm i'm mine is
and you've used the schwarzenegger i'll
be back we'll be back they'll be back
he'll be back i gotta go he'll be back
because
you know there's a lot of people today
that are gonna take a certain amount of
perverse glee and the fact that patrick
mahomes didn't have a great game he had
a great game he did everything in his
power he was the last guy
on the chiefs to to acknowledge that it
wasn't their night i mean he said after
the game he thought they had a chance up
until the last interception that devin
white
made in the end zone when at that point
there's no way it's too late in the game
there's no you got no chance up until
then he was holding out hope remember
remember the crazy
2002 game between the colts and the
bucks the monday nighter where
what was it was it the the colts and
tony dungy came back from the huge
deficit and won the game remember that
one yeah sure like i'm starting to think
the last five minutes like oh we've seen
lightning strike in this stadium before
and it's mahomes like he wasn't given up
until after that drive and we saw we saw
him throwing from
and we've seen him bro look at this he
throws from everybody position including
falling on the ground laying out
sideways
and and and it was so unexpected that
the guy that he threw it to it hit him
in the face
this guy
is beyond unbelievable yeah right that's
all there is it's beyond special i mean
he was playing at 80 and it was still
special i mean he was making throws that
like we talked about there was a few
where yeah they were tough catches but
they were on the money ridiculously
amazing throws and it could have changed
the game and that that's it's amazing
and mike
last thing because i love that you went
down this way because you're right
people are going to be on him i also
love the way he goes down he didn't like
try to be political on the way down
yesterday where oh you know let me not
throw another interception so people
won't blame me let me throw check downs
so at the end of the day we can look at
it and go like oh look his stats were
pretty good
he went down going wait i'm either going
to win this thing or we're going down in
flames and i don't give a damn and that
i love that aspect about him he wasn't
going to play the politics game and save
his you know aura you know for next year
and everything like that and i have a
lot of respect for my homes because of
that
the throw that he made when he spun
around and he unloaded it into the end
zone and byron pringle actually came up
with the ball like i i i was like oh
plea i was i was rooting for the replay
to show that
caught it yeah and then you can see he
didn't but just unbelievable and can we
put up the image of him laying out i
mean
to all the marv marinovich's out there
that have boys that they want to make
into quarterbacks make them short stops
first that's the quintessential short
stop deep in the hole getting the ball
laying out and firing at the first base
that's why he's so great because he's a
shortstop playing quarterback he's an
all-star shortstop playing quarterback
that's why he can make those throws
because he's got the arm to do it and it
doesn't matter what position his body's
in defies everything that we've ever
been taught about quarterback mechanics
and motion and bass and stance and
turning and torque it's just
whenever you get the ball whenever you
have to get rid of it you get rid of it
and you throw it toward the target now
you also have to have an incredibly
gifted arm that you've honed to
perfection through years and years and
years of practice but shortstop get him
to play shortstop in addition to
quarterback and that's how you craft a
patrick mahomes and and hope you know
that you've got everything out that the
skill and the god-given ability and the
genes and everything else but but the
shortstop is the the ingredient that
allows us to see moments like we saw
last night well it's it's it's
there there's he's amazing i mean come
on listen i know brady's the goat and
everything like that i get it but the
guy we watched last night is this ta
he's more talented than anybody we've
ever seen in the history of the sport i
mean that that's not even
i mean it's you know a very select few
can do some of the things he did last
night from the day he's taken over it
has been about mahomes and the team and
everything being around him it's
everything it's different than brady
brady got to play defense and run the
ball and and do some things like that
early in his career to where he got to
grow into this mahomes stepped on the
field and we went greatness take over go
ahead 50 touchdowns 5 000. first time
you ever got out there just go we never
heard from you texas tech go take over
the world take over the team he's
amazing he really is that's what stinks
about last night that he wasn't at 100
that we didn't get to see their starting
tackles and see a better show either way
hey that buccaneers defense was all over
him and but i i have respect for mahomes
just like you're saying no doubt and let
me let me just say this one last one
last bouquet for patrick mahomes
if you had taken and it tell me if i'm
wrong if you had flipped mahomes and
brady last night on teams well come on
same outcome if it's worse it's worse
brady's not going to be able to scramble
around and make some of the 497 yards he
can't walk 490 so that's what i mean so
the the game would have been 59 to 7. i
don't know what else to say that's
that's where this is where again i
become a tom brady hater it's not about
being a hater or tom brady i love brady
i do i just get exhausted by
i turn on tv shows after the game
and nobody talks about anybody on the
team of the buccaneers except for one
guy and i want to go that was like an
all-time super bowl defensive
performance that was a butt whooping
offensive line performance i know brady
was really good but damn can we just
give credit to somebody other than him
that's where i get frustrated with it as
you could tell
let me just add one last part to that
though
because if brady and i don't want to
take anything away from patrick holmes
he's young he's only been a starter for
three years brady's been down this road
so many times sure when he walks through
the door it changes everything so i
don't want
in suggesting
i think accurately if you flip mahomes
and brady the buccaneers still would
have won
there's still that aura that presence
that mandate that you know chastising
the teammate who was crying in the
locker room after the nfc championship
why the f are you crying we still have
work to do texting the teammates every
single night at 11 p.m on the dot we
will win every night leonard fournette
said that after the game every night
leading up to the super bowl just that
vibe that presence that aura that
determination not that patron homes
doesn't have it he's got it
when the game's on
i just think it's going to take time for
him to grow into the full tom brady
experience of what he bring into a
locker room so
who you know does that make mike
remembers block any better i don't know
no but it helps to have someone like
that around yeah what it does and that
takes time to grow into you know that's
a guy that's been around the block a few
times mahomes has his magical ways we
know that the team loves them you know
is he as good as brady in all those
areas no you know maybe not certainly he
hasn't been the experiences the battles
everything like that but still a
phenomenal leader and hey you know that
that i don't care who you got at
quarterback last night that was going to
be rough i mean i don't know what else
you can do like we said there was
certain plays in the game
where you sit there and you go wait are
they about to throw a screen pass
because they're letting everybody go by
and you're like no that was they were
trying to block them actually when you
saw the replay they just barely touched
shaquille or they barely touched jpp
that was the amazing thing to me more
than anything so uh awesome aspect uh i
i think the the next thing if we're
gonna hit one more super superlative you
know that i think is really important
we heard we heard mahomes you know talk
about
they defended the deep part of the field
they defended the sidelines you know
they really took everything away and
then you go well what about the middle
of the field and that's where the
dynamic duo come in
into factor and it's it's this the
linebackers deb and white levante david
we just i gotta talk more about them and
what they bring to the table because
you're playing defenses to protect the
deep part and the sidelines and things
like that whoa that puts a lot of
pressure on the guys on the inside and
levante david and and devon white
seemed like for the most part and i i'll
be excited to watch the film but did a
really good job in a lot of man-to-man
situations or zone coverages where it
ended up being like hey kelsey's in my
zone now i got to play him man-to-man
and we're just amazing with some of the
underneath in the middle of the field
type routes let alone what they do and
run defense and everything like that so
devin white lavonte david other than
like
brady i think these two guys were the
other guys that jump out to me to be
possible you know mvp players or of that
caliber
and devin white was doing that thing
that i saw him do all year long
specifically in the playoffs he'd just
come over and he'll say something to you
he's not going to push it right he's not
going to get himself a flag he knows how
much he can say right and and stay on
the right side
when he does it too
but there's a there's a there's still
there's still uh there's an edge there
right and uh and and i think that served
the defense incredibly well and look i i
don't know if the interception that
happened near the end of the game it
happened earlier would devon white have
gotten mvp consideration i i think it
was going to be very hard to overcome
the tom brady factor but devin white uh
did did what what i thought he would do
it just
the stakes weren't as high when he did
it all he did was keep the chiefs from
scoring a touchdown at all in the game
it wasn't the backbreaker that came in a
key moment when the chief still had a
chance to win the game last one for me
chris
and and this is something that we've
spoken about previously in the five
weeks since the end of the regular
season
this is the delay the coaching carousel
award and this is the ultimate example
the ultimate proof of how different it
would be you know i've argued in the
past that
the awards that are handed out the night
before the super bowl
they should be based on the full season
all the way through the super bowl the
only problem is the coach of the year
would be the coach of the team that wins
the super bowl the mvp would be the
super bowl everybody you know you'd get
it skewed by the outcome of the
postseason
so fine leave the awards as they are
but there is a huge difference
between how
the nfl teams that are looking for
coaches and general managers frankly but
but let's just focus on coaches because
this is the one because the general
managers keep hiring them however you
hire it's not as important as coaches
with the coaches
if you had waited until today
to fire up the coaching carousel yeah
say it i have a feeling things would
look a lot better todd bowles might be
like a little bit more in demand maybe i
i have a feeling i have a feeling todd
bowles
would probably get one of the seven jobs
right i have a feeling byron leftwich
who got
let me see i got to check my math here
zero interviews right
would would have gotten at least one
if if they had waited until
the day after the super bowl to start
the process i think you're on to
something mike
and judy batista who covers the nfl for
the nfl we can never forget that i know
the people who work for nfl network nfl
media nfl.com don't like it when we say
it when i say it i'll take the heat
you're working for the nfl so there's an
there's an
there's there's a problem there baked
into the to the cake
she reports that an owner said that
moving
the
coaching carousel from the end of the
regular season until after the super
bowl
would be unenforceable
what's unenforceable about it you know
what that means that's a cop-out by
whoever said that
and here's here's really what they're
saying
people would cheat
and the nfl doesn't like to chase
cheaters around
because number one it's hard to catch
them and number two the nfl typically
doesn't like to have to say
to the world
we got we got cheaters in here like like
just like last week with gruden and the
in the tampa the blatant gross tampering
with richard sherman
they don't like to have to flag for the
world
that they have cheaters every once in a
while there's a strategic reason for
doing it like with bountygate because we
need to show that we care about player
health and safety or with any patriots
scandal because there's such a
deep-seated resentment of the patriots
within the league office certain
portions of it and certain owners
we don't like that the patriots have
cracked the code or at least had cracked
the code but but don't give me this it's
unenforceable don't give me this but you
know it is enforceable nobody gets hired
until after the super bowl period nobody
gets interviewed until after the super
bowl period and if anyone's out there
interviewing coaches before the super
bowl we're gonna we're gonna put an
enforcement mechanism in place and we're
gonna whack you if you do it what's so
hard about that chris
do it i know i don't everybody presses
pause do your do all your research
behind the scenes do your work get ready
for your interviews yeah but the process
begins today no one gets hired before
today no one gets officially interviewed
before today
and if you and if you run a foul of that
you'll lose draft picks
i don't know it's not that hard to do no
it's not and you know i i really think
it's a great idea one to make it fair
for all the coaches and everything like
that two like why wouldn't the nfl want
to dominate the news cycle for the next
three weeks and all now be coaching
conversation instead of us trying to
squeeze it in during playoff talk and
things like that to me it's a way they
can dominate another month of the year
in the news cycle so that's where it
makes sense to me mike and i'm with you
there's too many people that are
qualified that you know get shunned here
because yes they're still involved and
they don't want to just go all in on you
know getting ready their resume and all
that type of stuff so uh i think you're
on to something i'm with you there and
the last part of one could have been
like one caveat let me just say one last
thing that i don't like just the last
thing is that i just
to what you're saying what i don't like
about everything you just said
is it just as me as an ex player
sometimes it just comes down to like man
the players always got to follow the
rules and it just seems like a lot of
everybody else doesn't always have to
follow them and that's where that gets
to me annoyed a little bit
the the caveat on all of this would be
in the five weeks between the end of the
regular season and
the the super bowl
you run the risk of
owners
making up their mind about who they're
going to hire and
it's just a charade after that right yes
but but you know what that happens
anyway they spend the last five weeks of
the regular season making up their mind
you think you think shot khan didn't
know damn well he was hiring urban meyer
the moment the last game ended it was
just a question of whether or not meyer
was going to take the job he'd made up
his mind just like daniel schneider had
his mind made up for months that mike
shanahan was going to be the coach of
his team after the 2008 season that's
the way it works they're going to make
up their mind anyway but this is a way
that forces everyone to wait
and then everyone's on a fair footing in
the best argument that that supports
this idea of waiting is that and we've
talked about this before but it bears
repeating chris that inherent conflict
that the assistant coach is feeling
as he should be
focused exclusively on the next game the
next game planning for the next game
doing your job for the next game
meanwhile you've got to carve out time
to prepare
to be interviewed by one team two teams
three teams four teams five teams
and this is your opportunity for career
advancement your opportunity for career
advancement is knocking at a time when
you have dinner on the stove
for your current employer and what are
you gonna do are you gonna walk away
from the stove when the pots getting
ready to boil and go answer the door are
you going to not go answer the door what
are you going to do you got to choose
and and as as one person said to me when
that assistant coach comes home at night
offensive or defensive coordinator to
spouse or significant other the question
isn't gee how's the game plan going for
this weekend the question is have you
heard anything more about that head
coaching opportunity do you know when
are you going to know when's the
interview how'd the interview go when do
you think we're going to get the job
well you know and and that that's human
nature right because that's that's what
they all aspire to do is become head
coaches so it creates a horrible
conflict of interest that we expect
these folks to navigate if you just wait
until the day to start it nobody has to
deal with that it's all equal footing
it's all fair and we have the full body
of evidence from the season that was
before we start making our plans for the
season that will be yeah that's right i
think i mean well said
hopefully the nfl will think about this
a little bit you know too i mean i think
you just bring up so many good points
and and like i said i just i don't
understand why now we're going to not
talk you know there's not going to be as
many stories surrounding the nfl the
next few weeks it'd be great to be able
to talk about the coaching interviews
and do all that stuff um let the
postseason dominate january and then let
the coaching search dominate february
prior to the scouting i love that years
that there is yeah that would be amazing
right you know and you can even make
press conferences at the combine hey
here's our new coach blah blah blah all
that i mean i think it fits well um i
want to give one more superlative i got
two more superlatives actually the um
the uh crying jordan meme um sorry
that's my crying jordan meme is my next
superlative because uh bye michael bye
as much as i think you're the greatest
athlete in the history of america
most people
will not view you that way anymore
that's for sure
most people you look at social media
last night it's you know hey rings the
rings tom brady's got seven the casual
fans just gonna chalk it up to that and
go bam he's the greatest of all time in
any sport whatever it is it's arguable i
i mean listen it's a great argument i
understand that but it's a real aspect
of the sports debate here in this
country and those type of things brady
you know now will be viewed as that guy
for sure in a lot of ways and uh be
interesting to see i think it's going to
cause a lot of arguments in barber shops
and locker rooms and everything like
that
i remember you thought that once brady
got to seven that's when he'd walk off
right the thing is
it's
you know he's a guy who once he climbs
one mountain he finds another mountain
to climb and so he's got to seven so
what what's his goal does he want does
he really want to get to ten there's no
way in hell he can get to ten i mean is
there if you get to eight
you know you basically just like crap on
every other quarterback in the history
of football you know
hey joe
hey joe you're half as good as me hey
terry you're half as good as me i mean
that's to where
it's just it's remarkable again listen
i'll say brady's amazing the way he
throws the ball still like you said he
climbed another mountain to me this year
in conquering the mountain of i don't
like to be hit or touched and he's on a
team that really protects the ball
protects him well they run the ball
and his arm is still
phenomenal i mean as you see last night
some of the throws he makes are just
it's still jaw-dropping the way it pops
out of his hands and everything like
that again you know i i will say yeah i
don't he's been very beneficial of
having some really good teams around him
but i just think in the casual sports
fans eyes from here on out
i think he takes over for michael jordan
as you know the guy here in america
and let me make one important point
about tom brady's overall self-awareness
that extends beyond the end of the game
can we put the photo back up please that
we just had of brady holding the trophy
there's an important detail here do you
see the t-shirt the t-shirt is not over
his shoulder pads that's become a thing
over the last 15 years where they just
slap the t-shirts on the guys while
they're out there it's got a strange
look it reminds me of peter boyle and
young frankenstein that all you really
need is the sport coat on top of the
frankenstein monster to complete the
ensemble brady knows how that looks
he got rid of the shoulder pads before
he put the shirt on another check mark
in why tom brady is awesome although it
would be funny to see him with the
frankenstein look with the shoulder pads
and the t-shirt under it but you saw
some guys last night like that i
remember the first time i ever saw it
with super bowl 42 first time i noticed
it eli manning had the t-shirt over the
shoulder pads and it's just it's again
these are the images that will resonate
for years to come brady knows that he
got rid of the shoulder pads quickly
before it was time to put that shirt on
a very little subtle point but that just
shows you that brady's mastery he's very
aware of everything
everything everything how everything
looks how everything feels everything
you got go ahead you got one more time
yeah the uh now's not the time uh award
all right then now now is not the time
no no no wait hold on hold on hold on oh
yeah that's right refs i don't want to
see you in the last four minutes of the
second quarter in the super bowl get the
hell out of here are you kidding me i
want i mean that's like
it's ridiculous
i i it's my one issue with the game
yesterday listen i know
the better team won i'm not even arguing
that
i'm arguing a deeper issue that comes up
in the nfl every playoffs now and i
don't know where it goes either
refereeing in the regular season has to
change or the way they referee in the
playoffs has to change
but what we saw last night and what's
going to be frustrating to me is
we saw
a whole bunch of playoff games played
one way
and then all of a sudden we got into a
crucial part of the football game last
night in the super bowl
and the game was called a different way
i don't know any other way to say it i
don't know any other way to say it and
that that to me bothers me a little bit
not saying that it would have determined
the game i still think the bucks win
that game no matter what but i do think
we are maybe entertained to a better
show
and a
more competitive game if the referees i
don't know just to me got involved in
some very ticky tack type plays for what
we've seen through the playoffs this
year in the nfl
and it was at a key moment in the game
where it still could have gone either
way and that kind of started the mini
avalanche now the chiefs had the whole
half whole second half third quarter
fourth quarter recover from it they
never did
but but i look i i i get what you're
saying and that that moment we talked
about earlier when tyron matthew made
the interception after leonard fournette
tipped the ball up to him
flag defensive holding
well i mean you know this is the this is
where it gets lost to me where i go
first off the ball hit the wall so it
was not catchable all right the ball hit
the wall behind the end zone the other
thing you're talking about you're
talking about the past interference i'm
talking about the second one all right
so wait so the first one let's go to
that
the evans the interception the tip ball
right all that it's a six yard turn
around i mean there was barely i mean
any there was just a little hand
jostling i mean
that that's been that was the one of the
least egregious ones i've seen of all
the playoffs i mean it hasn't been
called so that was huge hey the go route
down the left sidelines to mike evans
they tangled feet go watch i replayed
the play like five times after
he he stepped on breeland's foot and he
fell down
so to me that's not a moment you call
that and then also the debatable whether
that's catchable and then the one in the
end zone with honey badger you know the
ball hit the wall in the back of the end
zone and here's the other thing that's
being lost i think a little bit with
pass interference if a defensive guy is
standing there he's allowed to stand
there even if the wide receiver wants to
go that way hit and when he's there it's
his right to be there he just because
the receiver wants to go that way
doesn't mean he gets the green light to
just run the guy over and now we call
past interference that's another thing i
see consistently called with refs right
now in the nfl just bothers me either
way bucks were the better team not
trying to make excuses just didn't tune
in to watch the refs you know late in
the second quarter the uncatchable thing
is always difficult because what we see
on tv is skewed by the fact that the
player was prevented from making his
best effort to catch it so i think they
do air on the side of of saying it was
catchable you know it's got to be
grossly overthrown to come to the
conclusion it was uncatchable but i hear
what you're saying and randy mahomes
here's what you're saying we had that up
there she was uh yeah it was a little
bit last night i mean it's it's hard
look but again there's a big difference
between having that happen in the final
four minutes no doubt first half no
doubt the final four minutes of the
second half there were still ample
opportunities for the chiefs to overcome
it but but when you're in the halftime
locker room for 25 minutes and you're
thinking that the world is lined up
against you including the people in
black and white stripes it can be a
little a little deflating and uh well
fourteen to six it's hard to come back
seventeen to six are a lot different
than twenty one to six you know that's
where
that's where it's you know you go into
the locker room twenty one to six and
you start to go holy crap i mean one
more mistake and we're done it's over
and that's where it was you know a
little shocking altogether and yeah i
don't like it i don't like that the
referees kind of dictated that part of
the football game last night
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports